lo stesso penalista benvenuti
oggi andremo a tema un parco di
divertimenti andremo solo votanti note
più alte
super super divertente non ha segnato
poi riprovare infatti divertimento
virtuali sul rotolo sarà come andare a
per voi il giovane mi piace scena 16 10
48 ecco l'ultimo libro del vostro mi
piace scoprirete chi andate voi al parco
di divertimenti sulle montagne russe
salire col per tutti avrete iscrivetevi
i documenti chi mi è capitato mettetevi
comodi e andiamo al padre di
divertimento caduto questo le
orecchiette
anch'io ho avuto noi cosa questa non si
mangiano gli orecchini in ogni video
degli orecchini diversi ve ne siete
accorti non basta vedere i miei altri
video vedrete ogni votato gli orecchini
diverse automobili si sono qui a
l'immobile ma aspetta tutta la pizza
menu pizza
facciamole battendo il russo è meglio
non mangiare tra l'altro normalmente io
sarei superfi buonissima perché mi fanno
un sacco di paura anche se adori farti
divertimento però le montagne russe così
attimi con un tocco di nero anche solo a
guardarle
però qua andiamo a fare tutte le
montagne illustranti le più alte di
tutte quelle piante quello blu quella
rossa quella rossa ea voi invece fanno
paura le montagne russe vive solo di
commenta è così che non c'e guardare
sotto non vedere tutto sembra dover
risalire bello vediamo ora come sente
[Musica]
papà super divertente e ci spostiamo
stavolta viste più in alto aspetta mica
è finita malissimo
sembra di vedere coi video poi però io
guardo sempre su youtube il video della
montagna russa perché mi piace vederlo
mi do una lira ma so che di carica che
mi sembra di vedere quei video ma è già
finita se devo toccare ma guarda guarda
sta per salire dai divertente anche a
staffetta guarda come ti diro aiuto
eccoci qua ancora non eri ma questo è
quello dove rimane appeso qua che ti
rimettono uguale l'abbraccio mourinho
quelli che mi fanno più paura di tutti
rimane appeso con le gambe troppo dai
andiamo davanti
sì sì sì sì sì sì aiuto ok andiamo
davanti ai mezzi dio che come erano
pronti a farsi dire dove troviamo i
turchi stimi in questo parco di
divertimenti estendono per partire ma
che faccia di 6 metto tutta la vita vuoi
fare
[Musica]
vediamo questo è più bello
salendo talento tempo salendo senza
amore
normalmente questo migliorerebbe venire
un'ansia pronti per lei tutto inserito
questo piano
[Musica]
anche se non è vero è bellissimo dove
ricevere ma si dai questo rosso è più
bello di quello che mi sa che abbiamo
già finito purtroppo è solo lievemente
diverse che finiscono subito che è molto
bravi studio guardate vitale sta facendo
un sogno
vabbè lasciamo abitare lì a superare una
parata e andiamo a vedere le altre
giostre ricordo vediamo cosa cerco
hawaii sue mille bello altre montagne
russe
tale quando sono poco poco più indietro
dai appena arrivata nel secondo abbiamo
a mente certo bello ma questo è
bellissima tooro bellissimo fatto per
veloce diamo un voto a tutte le montagne
russe a questa che voto ti diamo allora
secondo me per il momento questa il
numero 10
capita di piacere angeli con alba in
luce dell'altissima ciao a tutti queste
curve ormai noti come le altre
eccoci qua stiamo entrare in un altro
parte i divertimenti quindi questo parte
si chiama islands vediamo che catapulta
quale mi pare strozzate di casa da bruna
le prime anni è successo a me qatariota
aveva paura cadetta voglio provare
questa dai saliamo come si fa a queste
bisogna salire da quattro in queste
bisogna salire come capita
[Risate]
e che ben possono che fare se la puoi
fare
fermato ma come hai rotto rossoneri
grande tutti tutti e due ma ormai le
rotte non potevano portare a roma tre
andiamo nella catapulta stessi sistemi
diamo e che l'acqua dai è ferma potevo
tallinn è ok ma che succede sotto le
trasportato da un'altra parte e un altro
parco un'altra azienda giostra più
gigante wow degli aerei
ora lo fa come stefano farina è forte
bisogna saltare sopra come abbiamo fatto
noi guarda presidente respiro film si
entra da sei mesi c'è scritto ecco
saluta l'italia e rosa inedite di quale
se fai non in quello giallo su dove sei
qui in giro da parte
ecco di divieto mi metto più in questo
giallo ok
[Musica]
che bello giro tutto praticamente puoi
decidere tu se se andare a destra
sinistra o sei pronta benissimo ma lo
faccia girare proprio stiamo andando
sempre più veloce sul primo round
abitare tuttavia vari in alto dove
evitare che questo sembra che soccorre
eccoci siamo tornati omnium in questo
quello che ha forse pride vediamo dovete
spiegare ad mio fare la fila o che
proprio come sempre super powers osè
bello adoro d'oro davvero come un parco
divertimenti bisogna pure per alla fine
e così quello dobbiamo aspettare che
ecco neanche così quasi detenuti vediamo
un po che cosa ci aspetta ma non parte e
un folle questa giostra vediamo stiamo
tirando emesso terrà nico degli
scheletri dice del fuoco vostro tutto
buio ha detto cadiamo giusto che di
acqua un albero stregato sono questi
rumori
paura c'è qualcuno là dietro è visto no
ragazzi bisogna avere sta cambiando la
dietro sono i mostri tipo di altri aiuto
controlla che non mi potete state e sono
qua che è uno con una falce ok siamo ci
stiamo
no non stiamo uscendo che pur salendo
molto in alto forse ci sarà una
montaggio salta ok almeno qui non ci
sono mostri perché ci stiamo girando
forse la dobbiamo vedere cos'è quello
dei gli occhi ma che francese qua che
chi può
usiamo sopravvissuti no ma sta tornando
dentro parla è la sede dove preferito è
il nostro dialetto che succede è sparito
nello store divanetto sarà stato un
magma tempo di non muoversi sì perché
siamo tipo su un tapis roulant aiuto
dove dobbiamo andare
wow ma anche che sarà sede telos o sei
fuori
siamo in un cimitero che corre e va bene
scappiamo da qua ok a sopravvivere tema
l'uscita qua ma come fatto qualcuno mi
ha ucciso bene torniamo al parco giochi
so che altro come programma la
maledizione di carne
proviamolo il pc qua dove bisogna andare
[Musica]
è iniziata la musica vuol dire che ci
stiamo avvicinando che bello soprattutto
un castello ma che bello non c'è fila la
cosa più bella è che non ci sono tante
persone non c'è fila ma lo è dovete
prenotare nota aspetta qui c'è dal cibo
e non lo posso fregati siamo in un
castello
guarda qui c'è una prigione ok a masino
mettiamo che arrivi e sarei venuto al
mondo pronti non arriva anche le oltre
portali a fianco di sabato grazie
ecco sta arrivando qualcun altro ma che
cos'è tutto verde tutto verde scendete
vogliamo andare in prima fila a quello
di aruba d'opposto queste non scendono
devi andare 4 ma qual è lo stesso
giornalista
abbiamo talento che succede tutto buio
luci semplici dentro la montagna ci
mancava pure la tempesta come abbiamo
fatto ma sopratutto cosa di sicurezza
aperto perché per le sorti brano non
passato ma che succede dopo evitato di
più ecco tiro per fortuna non sono
caduto bene di questa già prodotti è
capito niente allora che non funzionava
mi ha inquadrato un'ora non tutto era la
gente date qua c'è qualcosa con i piloti
quello a questo post ma ci voglio
provare questo sembra bellissimo la mia
mano si chiama l'inseguimento del
serpente
siamo arrivati ragazzi stiamo per salire
guarda c'è anche un elicottero così vedo
io l'elicottero
eccoci qua dove è vitale 6 sono i binari
e dal numero 45 no io non vedo vitale ma
siamo in una stanza diversa
e vabbè però questa giostra da sola ma i
fatti cui non c'è nessuno qui dove sono
io che sono una persona che arriva dai
dai sentite stendete aspetta
ecco fatto mi sono seduta a questi sono
singoli finite così 40 morendo e tipo
una lingua del vostro guarda al moscone
via martino
bello va velocissimo questo figo ma
guardatelo vederlo speriamo mi capiterà
bellissimo stato di persone che
aspettano questo è lo stesso per
popolare non si guarda te dice che
adesso c'è la parata andare tu non ti
chiamo non lo vedo eccole forse
controparte centrino fa guarda sta
arrivando 26 i trenini premio di
personaggi simbolo di rob lowe le pizze
o il caffè
no le fatine quasi altro cibo si
succederanno abbassare la blu ecco
vitali si ferma la pizza acque lento
preferita da guerra che c'è anche
l'altro cibo guarda il mio governo
guarda ci sono idonei wow mio prende
questa delle fatine qual è il vostro
preferito
bene direi che ora con la parata
possiamo concludere nostro ufficio o dio
nel porto di divertimenti è stato super
divertente tra il mio parco di
divertimenti assieme a voi la mia nostra
preferita è stata l'ultima quella della
lingua se ne sa lei mi piace se volete
vedere altri giochi rob 10 villa savo
passate se li puoi cliccare per vedere
inoltre altri video e casa su quella che
preferite
ciao